If you'd play your application to App Spot, you
can explore the entities in the data store using the
Admin Console. Let's take a quick demo of how
to get there. So to get to the Admin Console,
you go to console.developers.google.com. And it will list your
projects. This is one project here, and then you click
on that. You click on the project that you want
to investigate. And it will take you to the dashboard
for your project. So you see there's a, an App Engine
section that let's you get to various. Things about App Engine,
I think you already looked at that. So if you click
down here, you see the cloud data store option. And this will
take you to the dashboard for your data store. Dashboard shows
you various kinds of information about your project. You can get
statistics of all your entities, you get breakdown by property type.
You can get the total size of the entities that are stored
in the data store. See this here, the indexes?
You'll be learning about indexes really soon. So, go
ahead, you can go ahead and explore the, the
dashboard, see what kind of information is in there. What
I really want to talk about is the query.
So, if you click query, it takes you to
the page where you can find out information about
the entities that have been saved. This kind of menu,
just like in the local host. Admin Console lists
the kinds of entities that are stored. Right now
I only have profile, and these other two things
are internal to App Engine. I'm looking at the entities
of kind profile, I've only got one, that's the
profile that I just created. You can see the display
name, the main email, the tee shirt size. Can
drill down into it if you want. You can even
change the values here. Obviously you'd really only
want to do that during development. This is
where you would come to check your entities. And it can be a really useful tool.